this is the town of Shelton near the
Black Forest in southwest Germany and as
he walk around it looks like a normal
German town with one strange addition
upon some buildings there is a big fake
piece of sticky tape with a slogan that
translates as Stefan must not fall apart
unfortunately it's a bit late for that
the government here tried to pour for
geothermic energy and their boards in
total seven bore holes right behind the
Town Hall unlimited Stefan is a big
layer of anhydrate and underneath that
is a layer of ground water in a confined
aquifer the pressure is groundwater went
into the layer of an hydrate and formed
gypsum which expands by about 50 percent
unfortunately that means that the ground
is expanding bulging out and forming
cracks in almost every single house
that's standing here it took two weeks
for the first cracks to appear in the
decade since the drilling operation the
town hall has risen more than half a
meter and moved sideways by about the
same amount and that might not sound
like much and yes if everything had
shifted evenly it might not even be a
problem the trouble is that different
parts of each building have shifted by
slightly different amounts modern
buildings couldn't cope with that and
that Town Hall was built in 1546 the
result is cracking this water from this
confined aquifer is pushing up the bore
holes and what they are trying to do is
get the water out get the pressure down
from the confined aquifer so that it
doesn't even want to go up those holes
anymore so they're pumping at a speed of
around a liter per second the swelling
started with about a centimetre per
month now it's down to about a
millimeter per month but it's still
swelling and even a millimeter is still
way too much for every house
theoretically they can stop it but you
cannot just plug it like like a bathtub
that's not a single plane it's more more
three-dimensional and reality you would
need a big big plug and you don't even
know where it exactly is the drilling
company settled out of court for more
than a million euro but the cost of the
damage here is estimated at more than 50
times that and there are eight other
German towns with similar problems
geothermal drilling was popular and not
massively regulated and while the
industry and the country have learned
from those mistakes for this town that
knowledge comes a little too late
thank you very much to Constantine
Cronin he suggested this video in the
first place he also has his own YouTube
channel where he's building a 3d printer
from scratch go check him out